I think the hardest thing about parenting,
truly the hardest thing about parenting,
is that you look at your own childhood through the lens of a parent
now as opposed to how you've always looked at it,
which was through the lens of a child.
And children are much more forgiving
now that you have your own little person that you're in charge of.
You look back at certain things that happened
or the relationship you had or didn't have with your family,
and you look at it with so much regret and anger
and disbelief and confusion.
Because you look at the little person that you have,
and you know that you would never do those things to this person,
because the love that you have for them is so strong,
and the way you prioritize them in your life is different.
And then you have to ask yourself why you didn't get that.
And that'll take years to unpack.
And there's nothing that can make that process easier.
And there's no way to go back in time
and change anything that ever happened to you.
But I promise you that you will be a better parent by a dealing with
and addressing your childhood,
as opposed to forgiving, forgetting,
and moving on too quickly.
Because trauma has a way of rearing its ugly head
when you least expect it. And
if you are not going to be repeating
the same mistakes as your parents,
you're gonna have to Figure out what those mistakes were,
what they did to you, and how you're gonna do better. And that sucks.